[Music]
stereotypes and word choices often go
hand-in-hand for example a recent study
of massive text datasets found that in
the early 1900's Asians in the US were
characterized with words like barbaric
or monstrous
but that today words like passive and
sensitive are more common we see this
play out in the workplace as well job
ads for professional roles are often
peppered with stereotypically masculine
words as our performance reviews and
letters of recommendation these patterns
have consequences we know that when
people are described in ways that
reflect stereotypes stereotypes are not
only reinforced but they can also create
disadvantages
as an educator in a business school I
wanted to know if the case studies we
use in our classes also reflect
stereotypes so a team of undergraduate
research assistants and I read the 250
unique case studies taught in the GSB
MBA core curriculum the goal was to
analyze the text of each case study by
scrutinizing the descriptions of the
protagonists their situations and their
cultural context to look for any
potentially stereotypical language or
language patterns
we discovered a number of ways in which
stereotypes creep into the language
that's used in these case studies first
some case studies make sweeping
statements about entire countries for
example one case study includes comments
about the alleged rigid hierarchy of
Japan based on class age and education
another case references how physically
attractive Brazilians are here rather
than making sweeping statements examples
and data could instead be provided to
support the point being made in the case
study similarly some case studies fail
to provide sufficient context around
statements and wind up just reinforcing
these stereotypes for example on a case
study on an erectile dysfunction drug
there's discussion about how Eady leads
to a reduction in feeling masculine and
there's a reference to a report in the
case study that says that over 90% of
men and women reported that confidence
in a man's sexual ability is critical to
having a good loving relationship here
the case study could have provided a
little bit more context for example by
acknowledging that the study that they
are cited included only heterosexual
couples
and while the comments about a reduction
in feeling masculine may be directly
from the study that they cited this type
of statement can reinforce the
stereotype that a man's sexual ability
is and should be important to his sense
of masculinity third case study language
can promote and reinforce gender racial
and ethnic stereotypes for example a
case on a woman CEO opens up with her
reading to her three-year-old son and
kissing him goodnight before joining her
husband in the living room or another
case quotes a CEO as saying that the
best lunches in Japan are prepared by
wives at home most of these examples
reinforce the stereotype that women
should be wives and mothers but not
leaders
[Music]
first we should train case writers about
how easy it is for stereotypes to creep
into case studies so that they can be
attuned to the language of leadership
and strive to make sure that the case
studies they write do not inadvertently
reinforce stereotypes we should also
insist that whenever possible they
include relevant context and data when
making sweeping claims here at the
Stanford GSB we're already doing this
we're working on training all of our
case writers on the best practices
second for those of us using case
studies in the classroom we should
conduct an audit of language used in all
cases that we assign this is something
we're also doing here at the GSB we are
currently writing cover memos for any of
the cases that we found with potentially
problematic language and we're making
these memos available to faculty well we
obviously can't do this for all of our
cases we believe that faculty once
they're made aware of these issues will
begin to audit all of the cases that
they use
third as educators we can create a
simple rubric to help students see how
they might identify stereotypes and case
studies we can teach them to see if any
of the patterns we identified can be
found in any particular case they're
reading for example we can ask them to
underline country descriptions and
descriptions of protagonists and then
evaluate these for any sort of bias
finally as educators it's important for
us to make this a teaching moment once
we have raised issues of bias and the
case studies we can facilitate a
discussion of how language impacts other
managerial situations that all of our
students will experience in their
futures
for example bias can creep into writing
job descriptions letters of reference
hiring briefs or performance evaluations
we should teach them to scrutinize the
language that they use as learners
you
[Music]